bonsoir avec son d'elven et merci d'être
avec nous qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre
d'une manière globale de ce sommet où
les sujets je le disais sont extrêmement
riches demain l'ordre du jour va être
complexe
oui alors ce qu'on peut attendre surtout
ce que beaucoup attendent ce serait la
fin du laxisme et de la politique
d'apaisement savez la fameuse phrase que
reprenez souvent churchill api semaine
parler si la volonté d'apaiser un voisin
candidats à l'entrée dans l'union
européenne que la turquie qui n'est pas
du tout bénéfique plus on pratique cette
politique d'apaisement et on reporte les
sanctions à plus tard
bien plus la turquie d'erdogan devient
menaçante envers chypre envers la grèce
on le voit aussi envers la france a été
extrêmement radical années les appels à
la haine anti-française d'erdogan dans
tout le monde musulman à sont absolument
terrifiant les appels à la haine envers
l'autriche rappelez vous il ya deux ans
quand l'autre y pleuvent à expulser des
imams radicaux turc le le discours qu'on
a retrouvée qui maintenant pas dans les
réseaux sociaux était un véritable appel
à a frappé l'autriche et et l'autre aile
et l'attentât qui a eu lieu en autriche
n'est pas totalement étranger donc si
vous voulez cette turquie qui menacent
militairement le chypre et la grèce qui
veut s'emparer du gaz de méditerranée
qui menace la france et l'autriche
ça fait beaucoup et on attend depuis
très longtemps des sanctions puisque on
l'a bien vu à chaque fois qu'on trouve
des circonstances atténuantes
rappelez-vous la russie a été très
souvent sanctionnés et les mêmes qui ont
sanctionné la russie trouve toujours des
excuses pour ne pas vraiment fonctionné
la turquie et le résultat est inverse à
celui qui a été chercher c'est à dire
d'apaiser erdogan d absolument pas à
payer de plus en plus menaçants envers
l'union européenne et de son point de
vue la raison
il reste est que la force et vous voyez
ce qu'il fait le jour même de se former
le jour même du sommet européen
ils fêtent la victoire soit disant
glorieuse contre
l'arménie tout petit pays 111e armées du
monde
lui il est la onzième et l azerbaïdjan
la 60e
voilà c'est parti ce n'est pas trop
glorieux en fait de prendre en sandwich
est un petit pays qui a été aidé par
personne par personne sauf à la fin un
petit peu la russie et voilà aujourd'hui
ils fêtent la victoire contre les
chrétiens arméniens du caucase au moment
du sommet la symbolique est extrêmement
clair le symbolique de conquérant
ottoman alexandre del valle comment vous
expliquer cette indulgence que vous
venez très bien de nous décrire envers
la turquie vous parlez d'apaisement mais
enfin pour quelles raisons
l'upa sont autant de choses alors les
fausses raisons c'est les résidents
économie vous savez on nous dit toujours
oui c'est pour garder un marché où c'est
une fausse raison parce que quand il y
avait eu la sphère de ocha lane le
leader kurde yahia ya 20 ans ou d'autres
affaires la reconnaissance du génocide
arménien il y avait eu plein de menaces
de sanctions de la part de la turquie et
il était rien passé
donc on sait que c'est pas vraiment le
chantage économique c'est pas la peur de
perdre un marché parce que les turcs ont
encore plus besoin du marché européen où
on a délocalisé beaucoup d' usine là bas
notamment de voitures que que que l'
inverse on on pense qu'à surtout des
pressions des pays de l'otan et
notamment des états unis et de
l'angleterre qui sont régulés résolument
pro turquin vous savez que pendant la
guerre récente contre l'arménie
l'angleterre a été extrêmement proche d
d d d d agresseurs pure et et azéri on a
des pays de l'otan dont le coeur est
beaucoup plus pro turc que progrès coûte
roture que et pro azéri que pro
arméniens et donc l'otan alors vous me
direz c'est bizarre parce que ils se
rapprochent russie il a acheté des s-400
russe mais justement l'otan a très peur
de perdre ce pays qui était pendant la
guerre froide le flanc sud pour bloquer
la russie au maire claude et c'est vrai
qu'ils se rapprochent un peu de la
russie mais ils achètent très peu
d'armes russes qu'ont parlement à l'otan
et l'otan
on les essaie de faire des pressions
pour qu on ne sanctionne pas trop la
turquie pour pas qu'elle aille encore
plus vers la russie en gros c'est on
espère les garder et quinze jours quand
l'herbe logan fera mort ou trop vieux
peut-être que la turquie redeviendra un
bon élément de l'otan l'idée c'est de
préserver ce n'est plus membre de l'otan
merci alexandre del valle écrit marc
géopolitologue de nous avoir apporté
votre point de vue elle avait donc de ce
sommet européen merci à vous